welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and our guest
is Marcella etcheverry assistant
professor of history at Yale University
she is an interdisciplinary scholar with
a background in anthropology and
political theory professor etcheverry
research and teaching interests focus on
the relationship between political
subjectivity and social transformation
in Latin America from colonial times to
the present today we talk with her about
her forthcoming book indian and black
Royalists in the age of revolutions
empire and politics in the northern
andes 1782 1825 welcome professor
etcheverry thank you well let's begin
with an overview of your book tell us
about it so the book as you just said is
focused on the 1782 1825 period which
falls squarely within the age of
revolutions which is a moment when most
of the Atlantic world is in upheaval and
there's transformations in the political
systems of what at that moment were
colonies of the European empires okay
and so basically i look at the latin
america and Wars of Independence so
essentially the moment when Spain is
being rejected by people across a what
at that time were the colonies but of
course we have to think about the fact
that these were not yet the nations that
we think about today so I focus on what
is columbia today but was called New
Granada at that time specifically the
southwestern region of these Vice
royalty of new arena where there were
important numbers of indigenous people
and African descendent people who were
enslaved and also some of them free so
during the independence Wars this
becomes a region where most of the
people mobilized in favor of the Spanish
crown so particularly in
fittingly not in favor of the
independence cause I look at why this
happened so the guiding question of my
book is how to explain why indigenous
people and people of African descent who
we would normally expect to be against
the Empire or to have anti-colonial
interests are actually acting in favor
of the Empire and in favor of the
monarchy okay and the way that I do this
is by as I said I don't begin in the
1809 moment when the Wars of
Independence actually begin but I go
back in time into the colonial period
and I look at how exactly the political
relations and the political identities
of these people indigenous people people
fabric and the st. both free and it's
late were framed within the Spanish
monarchy and the Spanish Empire okay so
this is the first part of the book and
it's actually then followed by the core
of the manuscript which focuses on the
independence Wars and that's the part
when where I look at more how their
contingency throughout the wars is going
to affect the positioning of these
people as royalists in the in the
independence process so essentially the
book is contributing to a number of
fields because it's looking at
indigenous people people African descent
in the same frame which is not very
useful for Latin American history and
Atlantic history more broadly and it
also really rethinks the politics of
indigenous people and people of African
descent in the context of the age of
revolutions okay what led you to write
the book so as you said I have a
background in anthropology and political
theory so I had already been quite
interested in these courses or notions
about other nests in Latin America and
the moment of the independence process
becomes really crucial for understanding
how we think about the role of a what
today are mostly minorities in
American nations in the construction of
the nation-state so I was reading a lot
and thinking a lot about how to
incorporate these people into these
narratives of nation state formation but
i came across the interesting and by all
means paradoxical case of this royalists
in southwestern New Granada and there
were always mentions on of them but
generally just by passing there was no
real problematization or even attempt to
explain it they emerged first of all it
during the 19th century in the context
of the independence Wars when Simon
Bolivar whom you know most of the people
have heard about because he was quite
important in finalizing the independence
of the South American region and so he
was trying to go south into Peru to to
do to have a connection with the
southern independence movement and he
was precisely blocked in this region
that I study in the the papasan region
and the southwest of Colombia because
the royalists were so prominent and so
successful for so long between 1809 and
the 1820s and so again i was looking at
how these Royalists were portrayed in
the nationalist narratives written in
the 19th century and usually you would
find references to the fact that they
had been quite backward or that they
were somewhat fanatical in religious
terms that they were really not able to
kind of grapple the situation and the
opportunities that the obviously the
anti-colonial movements were posing or
finding and so this for me was
completely insufficient and
interestingly I didn't only find these
types of explanations in the 19th
century literature but I started to see
it how it reverberated somehow in the
contemporary understanding that scholars
handle about again minorities ethnic
minorities who are sometimes
so to have a certain type or scholars
historians social scientists expect them
to have a certain type of political
identity or political consciousness and
so what I'm referring to more
specifically is for example there are
like two sides of this debate on the one
hand thinking about indigenous people or
people of African descent being
naturally anti-colonial like I was
saying before that's when people would
normally expect them to be on the
insurgent side or some people even the
19th century scholars would say well
definitely we can expect them to be
royalist we can expect them to be in
favor of the crown precisely because
they are so backward and their political
consciousness is so insufficient and so
unsophisticated if you will that then
that explains everything and that would
be where the two sides where and for me
this became an incredible opportunity to
revisit the historical moment and to
think about the process from the point
of view of the historical actors and at
the same time I would be contributing of
course to the literature and to our
thinking about nation state formation
about colonial history more broadly and
of course about the politics and the
political consciousness of the popular
classes in Latin America and the
Atlantic world okay very interesting I
would love for you to tell us you know
what you found when you examined the
period prior to the independence in
terms of you know what did you find
about the people how do you explain
their embrace of Spain vs vs not
embracing yeah that's a great question
and that's exactly where the whole story
begins and where my mythological
approach becomes important and yes I am
going to ask you how you did your
research too so by all means so should I
move into that one or whatever however
you like to approach because part of the
the point here is that because we are
thinking from the present point of view
we tend to already assume the way that
things are going to your right yeah so
one of the challenges that I myself have
to be reminded of but also that is the
conclusion of how this project has
evolved is that when we go back in time
we don't know that outcome and we can
actually think about the process in a
more open-ended way right so what I'm
trying to get to here is that perhaps we
shouldn't talk about this in terms of
why they didn't embrace the independence
movement because that is assuming that
the independence movement in itself
exists as something given when the
moment actually begs the possibility
that these things were much more
incoherent that ideologies were not as
clear-cut as we tend to want to remember
them and reconstruct them so this was
happening not only in the royalist side
but also in the independence or
insurgent side right and this is
something that of course has been quite
well developed recently in the
historiography as a whole trying to
rethink the independence movement
perhaps by questioning the possibility
that these people were envisioning
independence from the beginning of let's
say 1808 1809 that obviously leaves open
the possibility of thinking about the
royalists in the same terms how they
envisioned transformations within the
monarchy and within the Empire and so by
looking at the colonial late colonial
context and here we're talking about
1780s which is already as I said before
within the age of revolutions which
means that there's already incredible
transformations taking place in in the
hemisphere nonetheless what I'm trying
to get to is how the political
identities and the legal identities of
of these people indigenous people
enslaved and free people of African
descent are really in dialogue with the
monarchical framework so that means that
it's very hard for them to
necessarily envision something outside
because what they're doing is actually
having a dialogue having a conversation
within the possibilities that that they
have at that time so in terms of how I
did the research this is also important
because the fact that that indigenous
people and people of African descent
were generally excluded from narratives
of Independence and modern state
formation modernization more broadly in
Latin America has to do with the fact
that they are relatively absent as
voices as explicit voices producers of
documents in the sources that as
historians use to do our research of
course it's an incredible challenge and
for a long time people used this
argument to actually let's say
comfortably exclude them from the
narrative but of course this has been a
challenge then transform and it has been
an object of incredible epidemiological
reflection among scholars and so what I
did was basically use documents that
were not produced by these subjects by
indigenous people or by people of
African descent but that of course
reflected some of their actions and some
of their positioning throughout the war
and an throughout the late colonial
period and that when they're red
creatively you can actually get two
important elements of their importance
doing the process so I'm thinking mostly
of course letters sermons correspondence
between colonial officials and military
officials because something crucial that
I have to explain here is that I've been
interested both in the legal dimension
of this process so in other words as i
said before how the legal identities of
indigenous people three people and
enslaves are constructed within the
monarchic of context but I'm also very
interested especially in the
independence war
earth in the process of the rise of
military opportunities for them to
become course political actors in the
whole context of the war so that's why
military documents also became crucial
and I did my research in Spain in
Ecuador because the archives that hold
documents for this region of of
southwestern Colombia are actually in in
Quito also the John Carter Brown library
here in in providence rhode island and
of course colombia bogota okay so when
you were doing your research did you
come any across anything that surprised
you that you weren't anticipating or
perhaps expecting yes and it's
interesting because it has to do
precisely with the challenges that the
project post for myself as much as I
wanted to really break out of some of
the most limiting preconceptions about
these people and about the region I it
took some time to realize for example
that I had to completely strip away this
this topic and particularly the people
that I was studying in southwestern
arena of their connection with new
arenas center which is Santa Fe because
Santa Fe is going to very early on start
to experiment with independence and
autonomous rule but so if I continue to
frame the story within the Colombian
history which is ultimately wear it
today still stands right because we tend
to project back columbia the country the
region the geography into the past and
of course that would lead to think maybe
I'm writing Colombian history of the
19th century right but in fact that
became a huge obstacle for me to really
understand the dynamics of these
royalist people and eventually ended up
making the connection with actually the
south which is the Peruvian rice royalty
back remained as a royally stronghold
pretty much until I was
you before until Simon Bolivar finally
is able to cross south and basically
this articulate is a very strong Spanish
stronghold but throughout the time of
the of the Wars of Independence
popaganda region that I that I look at
is actually tied to Peru and and that
really explains why it's able to
maintain itself both politically and
militarily during the war so it really
entailed breaking away from the from the
framework of colonial history completely
and entirely to start to think about the
Royalists really in a more positive and
creative way instead of thinking about
them in the framework of colonial
history that is relatively based on
negative perspective that they are that
these people are anti Cologne and I'll
Colombian right anti-republican try to
think about them beyond that negative
conception that we haven't heard it and
when you look beyond that negative
perception what do you found what are
the characteristics why did they embrace
Spain why did they not want to go off on
their own for instance why did they not
want to go on not on their own well
interestingly and this allows me to
expend a little more on what's happening
in Spain itself okay because after 1809
the Spanish monarchy enters into a huge
crisis Napoleon Bonaparte they invade
Madrid and basically takes over the
government and there's a small group of
spanish liberals that move to the south
of spain in Currys and they start to
create a you know an insistent
resistance against the the Napoleonic
invasion and they're able to maintain
connections with the Spanish American
territory that again here is when they
start to really stumble and experiment
with autonomy because they realize that
the government in Spain is no longer
there and that leaves a huge space for
experimentation but on the other hand
this is also a moment when as I find in
my in my research and write in my book
the people from
what we might call these royalist and
Plato or bulwarks are going to negotiate
their positioning within the monarchy in
the new terms in a very open-ended and
inflexible manner because of course as I
was in before as much as the
independence project is an open-ended
project the the Royalists as well are
reinventing what it means to be part of
this monarchical system and what it
means to be a Spanish vessel so when you
think about indigenous people to give
you another example or more concrete
example people are really trying to
think about how to negotiate taxes for
example or how to negotiate community
you know who has authority to do what
and on what terms of course military
relations here play a huge role my when
you think about slaves of course freedom
becomes a huge element of negotiation
but it's not simply freedom in a vacuum
over its not freedom like we tend to
think about it like as an abstract value
but it really is freedom constructed
within these monarchic Oh relations and
negotiating in terms of what it means to
be part of the monarchy according to
what they need to have and I actually I
should clarify the desert slaves that
are working mostly in the Pacific region
of new arena so the work really does
have like two different landscapes in
which this war is taking place the
Andean region where most of the
indigenous people are and the Pacific
lowlands for most of the people of
African descent free and enslaved are
okay living and then lastly what you
conclude in your book so there's a
couple of things and i think as i
introduced the whole project this is
clearly an a work that illustrates the
importance of moving away from
conceptual very rigid categories for
example to move away from the academy's
between reactionary
revolutionary because the the work
really allows me to to redefine what it
means to be political in this period and
to think in a more open-ended way about
the politics of indigenous people and
people of African descent regarding the
broader context for example of the age
of revolution history it's important to
remind ourselves that for the most part
the history of the age of revolutions
has been written from a North Atlantic
perspective and so we know a lot about
you know us revolution and we also know
a lot about the Haitian Revolution and
these are stories that really do tend to
privilege the revolutionary trope and
that feed really well with this idea of
radical breaks but I think that if we
move into the specific and the N region
which is where I am focusing my study we
really gain a lot in understanding the
complexity and the diversity of the
politics of people of course from all
classes and so in that sense for example
the Latin American case really adds our
understanding of breaking away from
again from the dichotomies that we're so
used to that liberalism and royalism in
the Latin American case and indicates
that a study are not necessarily
opposites for example because as I was
telling you the liberal project that
evolves in the Spanish in the Spanish
Peninsula is eventually going to be
crucial for the way in which royal east
the loyalties are going to be redefined
during this period to ultimately people
are thinking about a loyalty to the
crown that is in a large extent liberal
and these are things that people don't
necessarily put together very often when
they think about the history of this
period yeah very interesting thank you
so much for being here with us today and
sharing some of your work thank you for
more information about professor
etcheverry enter work please visit our
website at
edu / Macmillan report be sure to join
us again for another episode of the
Macmillan report made possible through
funding from the Whitney and Betty
Macmillan Center for International and
area studies at Yale
you